in the opening scene we are introduced
to a young farm boy named Jack who lives
in the Kingdom of Closter with his
father Jack is fascinated by a tale
about Giants and asks his father to read
it to him before bedtime as his father
Begins the story we are taken to the
story's World many years ago a group of
monks found magic beans which they hoped
would create a pathway to God but to
their dismay all they did was fart
instead these beans sprouted into
something unexpected a gateway to G the
place Between Heaven and Earth where
menacing Giants lived these Giants
descended through the beanock and
Unleashed Havoc upon the world the human
race suffered greatly as they stormed
the castle and plundered the palace one
day an ancient King Eric discovered a
solution to subdue the Giants he melted
the heart of one of them and created a
magical Crown which he used to banish
them back to ganta imprisoning them
forever as the king passed away the
remaining five magical beans were buried
with him and the tail became a legend
Young Jack worries about the possibility
of the Giants Breaking Free again but
his father reassures him that it's just
a story and the Giants don't exist after
the old man departs Jack continues to
read the story and learns that the
Giants will return to annihilate
Humanity Jack's not sleeping tonight on
the other hand a queen simultaneously
reads the same story to her little
princess Isabelle she says that King
Eric was real and that she's of her
blood in response the little girl
mentions that she's seen his grave this
raises concerns for her mother as she
realizes that Isabelle has been
wandering around nevertheless she
doesn't say anything believing that
Isabelle should know everything before
ascending to the throne one day the
scene then fast forwards 10 years and a
grown-up Jack now lives with his uncle
after his father's death one day he is
sent to town to sell their horse and
cart when he reaches there Jack gets
distracted by a theater that is
retelling the story of King Eric and the
Giants upon sneaking in he catches sight
of a beautiful girl in the audience and
immediately develops a crush on her
amidst the show a group of thugs begins
harassing harassing the girl so Jack
decides to intervene despite getting
punched in the face he attempts to
reason with the troublemakers to let the
girl go right then a group of Royal
Guards led by Elmont arrives prompting
everyone to kneel the girl mounts a
horse revealing herself as none other
than princess Isabel after their
departure Jack walks out only to
discover that his cart has been stolen
meanwhile at the palace Lord Roderick
and his assistant Wick are seen
strolling down a corridor discussing his
marriage to the princess during this
they stumble upon on a monk but they let
him pass shortly afterward rodri enters
his room and realizes that the monk has
made off with the magic beans he then
immediately orders the guards to seal
off the town Gates and apprehend the
monk outside the monk approaches Jack
and offers to pay him 10 times the
horse's value but lacking immediate
funds he hands Jack the magic beans as
collateral and asks him to bring them to
the monastery in exchange for a huge sum
of money Jack hesitates but the monk
grabs his horse and escapes cautioning
him not to get the beans wet I've seen
Gremlins I know how this goes back at
the castle princess Isabelle is brought
before her father King Bramwell who
scolds her for leaving the palace
without an escort she tries to make him
understand that she is not a baby and
that she can roam around freely but he
is having none of it instead he declares
that she will soon get married to
Roderick hearing this the princess gets
upset so she leaves the room abruptly in
the meantime Jack returns to his uncle
who is incensed at him for exchanging
the horse for beans freaking beans Jack
are you stupid he angrily flings the
beans and reprimands Jack for his lack
of responsibility or brains or anything
at all really urging him to act more
like a grown-up later that night
princess Isabelle disregards her
father's words and sneaks out of the
palace however when she is caught in a
heavy rainstorm she seeks shelter in a
nearby Farmhouse coincidentally it turns
out to be J back at the palace rodick
and Wick have caught the Monk and are
interrogating him about the magic beans
but he refuses to divulge anything this
infuriates rodick so he slices the
Monk's throat with his sword whoa
thought this was PG as the rain
continues one of the beans beneath
Jack's house begins to get wet Jack and
Isabelle have a brief conversation
during which she expresses her gratitude
for his earlier Intervention when he
asks her about what she's running away
from she mentions that she's looking for
an adventure Jack then gives her his
story book hoping she can find what she
is looking for their conversation is
abruptly interrupted when the house
begins to shake violently moment later a
massive beant stock bursts through the
floor and grows rapidly Towards the Sky
taking The Farmhouse along with it Jack
is thrown out of the house while
Isabelle gets stuck inside Jack
hurriedly gets up and clings onto the
house as it continues to rise he loses
his grip and plummets managing to grasp
only Isabelle's bracelet the next
morning King Bramwell wakes him up and
asks why he has his daughter's bracelet
Jack then explains the incident in
detail prompting the king to dispatch
his men to rescue his daughter following
this Jack Rob rrick and Wick volunteer
to join the king's Knights led by Elmont
and his second in command craw they
embark on a Relentless Ascent of the
beanock scaling it day and night without
rest upon reaching a certain height
Rodrick who has some hidden agenda in
mind secretly instructs Wick to cut off
the Rope which causes the guards to fall
to their deaths the following day they
make it to the top and discover the
Giant's realm before advancing further
rodk and Wix stopped Jack and forcibly
seized the remaining beans from him
however the boy manages to hide one
being for himself as they continue their
Journey they come across Isabelle's
Footprints as well as the book Jack had
previously given her when she asked for
adventure she didn't want a stupid book
she ditched it at this point they decide
to split into two groups one consisting
of Jack Elmont and craw and the other
including rodri Wick and a guard a while
later Elm Mon's group comes across a
herd of sheep and decides to hunt one
for their meal unbeknownst to them
there's a trap resulting in Jack and CW
getting captured they somehow manag to
free them M themselves but soon hear
something approaching sensing imminent
danger Elmont and craw take cover behind
a rock and a tree while Jack hides under
water soon after a gigantic figure
appears and finds craw he tries to run
away but the giant gets to him in a few
leavs As It prepares to eat him Elmont
comes to his aid but he also ends up
getting captured following this the
giant takes them away and Jack follows
meanwhile the other group reaches the
edge of a cliff it's at this moment that
rodk tricks the guard and pushes him off
the Cliff moments later another giant
appears and eats Wick rodri manages to
save himself by pulling out the magical
Crown just before the creature attacks
him in the next scene Jack follows the
giant to their stronghold where the
two-headed giant leader named Fallon has
caged Isabel it asks about how she ended
up there but she doesn't answer not long
after Elmont and craw are brought there
as well Fallon interrogates them and
when craw becomes confrontational the
Giants devour him after a while rodri
walks in wearing the crown which compels
all the Giants to kneel before its power
but instead of rescuing Isabel and
Elmont he ascends to the throne and
declares himself as the Giant's new
leader we are powerless before the
cringe of the crown he then orders the
Giants to serve as his army and conquer
the world starting with the kingdom of
cloy meanwhile Jack hides himself from
the Giants and eventually locates
Isabelle and Elmont who are being
prepared to be eaten while the giant is
facing away he hands Almont a knife
allowing him to cut himself free shortly
after the giant grabs Isabelle and
prepares to chop her up but in the nick
of time Jack takes a cooking knife jumps
onto its back and stabs it to death
after this the trio makes their way out
on the way Jack helps Isabelle by
applying some herbal medication to her
wounds making her feel better the three
of them soon reach the edge where they
find a giant sleeping Jack quickly comes
up with a plan he puts a swarm of bees
in the giant's face and that's a plan
for sure and hastily retreats to hide a
few moments later the giant becomes
agitated loses his balance and tumbles
off the the cliff despite eliminating
the threat Elmont decides to stay back
emphasizing his need to retrieve the
magical Crown from rodri as a result
Jack and Isabel reluctantly bid him
farewell and descend the beanock at the
base of the beanock the king in the
town's folk witnessed the deceased
Giant's body fearing the tale turning
into reality the king orders his men to
cut down the beanock sacrificing his
daughter's life for the sake of the
Kingdom as night falls Jack and Isabelle
take a break to look down at their
Kingdom from the heights the atmosphere
suddenly takes on a romantic turn and
the two end up kissing the beans got wet
Jack and now so have I unbeknownst to
them the process of cutting down the
bean stock is rapidly underway the next
morning at goua an army of giants led by
rodri reaches the brink seeing this
Elmont launches an attack on him
sparking a brawl between the two in the
course of their struggle rodick
inadvertently drops the remaining beans
at one point of the fight he shoves
Elmont to the edge nearly causing him to
fall despite this Elmont manages to
grasp rodri's sword sword and stab him
to death but in an unexpected turn of
events Fallon grabs roderick's dead body
and retrieves the crown he then puts it
on as a ring and declares himself as the
new king of the cringe on the other hand
the king's forces has successfully cut
off the beanock triggering a violent
Tremor Jack and Isabelle feel it and
quickly realize that they're about to
fall as a sheer mass of the stock
hurdles down Elmont jumps off and
reaches the stock just in the nick of
time meanwhile Jack asks Isabelle to
hold him tightly as he grabs a rope and
swings down like fraking Tarzan the pair
land in a field while Elmont manages to
jump in water successfully saving
themselves in the aftermath the king is
more than happy to have his daughter
safely returned Isabelle confides in him
about rodri's treachery prompting the
king to express his regret for his
mistake she also introduces him to Jack
the hero who saved her life the king
then proceeds to reward Jack
acknowledging that no amount of
gratitude is enough for his heroic Deeds
following this Isabelle rides back to
the palace with her father however it
turns out that the threat isn't
neutralized yet Fallon finds the
remaining beans and throws them in the
water prompting them to sprout instantly
the Giants then climb down onto the
beant stocks and make their way down
Jack notices them descending so he
rushes to inform the king but just a few
minutes later the Giants land on the
base and make their Chase they begin
killing the King's Men one after another
meanwhile at the palace Elmont readies
the Army for battle preparing defenses
such as hot oil and archers as soon as
the survivors enter the palace the
guards under Elmont command ignite the
oil they simultaneously lift up the
drawbridge to keep the Giants at Bay
Fallon manages to jump on but Elmont
strikes him with the arrows pushing him
into the fire despite this Fallon
manages to swim underwater and survive
now the rest of the Giants prepare to
pull down the drawbridge with large
hooks where' they get hooks while the
guards try to hold the bridge the king
instructs Jack and his daughter to go to
his chamber and alert the other kingdoms
following this Isabelle leads Jack
through a shortcut passing King Eric's
grave once they get into the chamber
they feel some vibration emanating from
beneath not long after Fallon emerges
from the floor prompting the pair to run
away outside the guards Elmont as well
as the king struggle to hold on to the
bridge as the Giants throw burning trees
and heavy objects thus weakening their
defenses on the other hand the chase is
cut short as Fallon grabs Isabelle after
breaking through the wall in an attempt
to rescue her Jack grabs an Axe and
jumps towards the giant but he's also
captured Fallon is about to eat him when
Jack at the last last moment throws the
remaining Bean into the creature's mouth
they instantly start to grow in his
stomach and rip his body apart as a
result Fallon's hand with the magical
crown falls into the ground meanwhile
the other Giants destroy the drawbridge
and make their way inside they March
towards the humans but before they can
inflict any harm they voluntarily throw
their weapons and kneel down it's
because of Jack who walks out wearing
the crown finally taking control of the
situation and looking the cringest of
them all the scene then skips ahead by
several years and we see Jack and
Isabelle now a married couple reading
the ending part of the story to their
children the kids ask about the Crown's
whereabouts to which Jack responds that
it's in a safe place where no one can
see it as time elapses the magic Crown
is crafted into St Edward's crown and is
secured in the Tower of London subscribe
for more videos like this turn on
notifications and leave a like to help
the channel out thank you for watching